et pour un public voulant pratiquer un
sport de commun sans contact violent
le body karaté est un art martial récent
véronique mesnil de vidéos multiple
championne de france de karaté et
experte fédéral anime un cours le
vendredi à rambouillet le body karaté
s'est déhanchée nement de karaté fait
sur de la musique ce qui permet de
travailler notamment le cardio toutes
les chaînes musculaires et évidemment
dans une bonne ambiance
il yad'abord l'échauffement la partie
body karaté et vers la fin on fait un
petit peu de renforcement musculaire on
a décidé cette année avec les membres du
bureau de recréer cette dynamique
en ouvrant cette section et comme vous
pouvez le voir il ya beaucoup de monde
ce soir
le cours a réouvert pour la rentrée car
de nombreuses demandes ont été faites
depuis sa fermeture quelques années plus
tôt ils sont plus d'une quinzaine
aujourd'hui et le body karaté
patrice hardy par attentes des
différents c'est plus festif mais pas en
tenue bien que 90% des participants en
france soient des femmes
cette activité est accessible pour tous
c'est cette mixité que le karaté sport
de rambouillet veut promouvoir
c'est surtout de remise en forme ça
combat sur soi même surtout donc c'est
pour les hommes pour les femmes pour les
jeunes hommes les jeunes filles enfin
voila c'est accessible à tout le monde
je trouve qu'on est plus détendue dans
le body karaté que j'aime plus faire du
sport de combat que du genre de la danse
ou du proxy ses objectifs de l'année
pour les élèves
mémoriser un maximum d'enchaînements en
rythme avec la musique
la séance a lieu tous les vendredis à
20h au stade du vieux moulin de
rambouillet